hey this is presh talwalkar
in the game of tetris there are seven
pieces each made up of four square units
the shapes are called tetrominos in
mathematical literature
can you use one of each piece to form a
7x4 rectangle
if so find a way if not prove why it's
impossible
i thank dr perkins for sending me this
delightful problem
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
[Music]
the answer is that it's impossible
and we will demonstrate the solution by
using a graph coloring
consider a 7x4 rectangular grid
color the squares alternately light and
dark like a checkerboard
this is one way you could color the
squares but this is not the only way
you could actually color the squares in
another pattern
but in either case there are an equal
number of 14 light squares and 14 dark
squares
now let's consider a coloring of the
tetrominos
first let's consider the following six
tetrominos
let's imagine coloring the squares
alternately light and dark like a
checkerboard
this is one way you could color each
piece
but there's another way
that you could color the pieces
but in either case each piece always has
an equal number of two light squares and
two dark squares
these six pieces always have 12 light
squares and 12 dark squares
now let's consider the t tetromino
what happens when we color it like a
checkerboard
here's one way you could color it
and here's another way
the t tetrominol always has two more
squares of one color
either it has one light square and three
dark squares or it has three light
squares and one dark square
so if we could make a 7x4 rectangle
using one of each piece then the seven
tetrominos would combine for a total of
14 light scores and 14 dark squares
but six of the tetrominos always have
the same number of light and dark
squares for a total of 12 light squares
and 12 dark squares
the t chatromino however creates an
asymmetry it either has three light
squares and one dark square or it has
three dark squares and one light square
using one of each piece we will either
have a total of 15 light squares and 13
dark squares or a total of 15 dark
scores and 13 light squares
the seven pieces can never combine to
have exactly 14 light scores and 14 dark
squares thus it is impossible for them
to form a 7 by 4 rectangle
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon if you have a
math topic you can email me presh
mindyourdecisions.com